and with that I just have two more words
to say Obama I will build a great great
wall on our southern border and I will
have Mexico pay for that wall I don't
know who created Pokemon go Hilary's
trying to appeal to young voters there's
a little bit like your relatives who
just signed up for Facebook but I'm
trying to figure out how we get them to
have Pokemon go to the polls I don't
know why that's funny I have been
against Japan but the fact of the matter
is most of them are travel single men
who masturbate to anime anime anime you
have abundant hitches what do I know I
mean I haven't seen Evangelion FBI
agents investigating her use of a
private email server do you all know
something about the content of emails
click on man you've got Bernie Sanders
refusal to drop out of the presidential
race
the editorial pushback against Bernie
Sanders the calls for him to drop out
and
I
Otto I a mediocre cigar
[Music]
make it as clear as possible as to why I
am endorsing Hillary Clinton make
America again
chuka chuka chuka key so they are a
celery root blue Chevy Platanias Amano
Osuna telomere messed up so stay current
aside or okay no LaRussa semana hunger
to stamina Tichina so change Oaxaca very
dangerous all the high dilution
[Music]